[Music]
okay let's get started with this
model monitoring example so i'm going to
open up a new our markdown file from a
template
so i've got all these different
templates from you know the packages i
have installed here
and i am going to use a flex dashboard
i really like the flex dashboard package
for a lot of different situations like
you know making really pretty shiny apps
without much
effort um two you know dashboards
i don't want to use shiny with but i
want like a dashboard kind of a
situation
so that's we're going to use here so i
am going to
um
let me save it i'm going to call it this
monitor.rmd
here and then the title so i'm gonna
this is going to be a dashboard for
monitoring a model for traffic
crashes so the data here the data in the
model predict
the probability that a crash involves
an injury it's crashes that are in the
city of chicago
and the data comes from the city of
chicago we have all this information
about
what the crashes are like and then we
predict whether the crash involved an
injury
so flex dashboard we have all these
different
it is a very flexible tool um you can do
columns or rows i am going to actually
change this out and make this
um the storyboard mode
here which is pretty nice and then
it turns out that almost all of the
logic for the model monitoring is going
to go here in the setup chunk so we're
gonna have a really big setup chunk
with lots of code and then actually less
code down
to create the dashboard itself and when
it's time to monitor
something i think it's nice to kind of
make clear in your head what are the
pieces that you need
and so one piece that you need is your
model
so your model is deployed somewhere
um in this case uh it's a model that i
already trained i have another
video that shows how i trained it it's
deployed
using a plumber api um on our studio
connect but
but really that model could be anywhere
you just need to be able to get to it
from our which of course we have
tons of options for being able to do
that and then you need your to get your
new data
so the new data that's coming in that
you want to be able to
see how is my model doing with this new
data
and then your metrics you know the
metrics that you had back at the
testing time and then your you know the
metrics
that we we would measure over
time as we continue to move forward
so these are kind of the pieces that we
need to get going
let us talk about how to get these
things so to get the data
often the easiest thing is just to go
back to when you trained the model
this is the github repo where i have all
the code i used to train the model
originally and so let's just go to the
beginning of that
whole script and get the um code that i
used
to train the model but instead of
getting two years of data
let's just get two weeks of data what
will happen is as i
run this dashboard week after week after
week it will get
newer and newer crashes as time passes
so let's run this and make sure it works
so what this is doing is going
to the city of chicago getting the new
crash data and we have you know the
information about the weather condition
the traffic way type and whatnot and
then whether there was an injury or not
so that's one piece we need the new data
the next piece we need is we need the
model
so to handle the model we're going to
use the hdtr package
we're going to use um jsonlight
the model in this case is
deployed as a plumber api on rstudio
connect
it it doesn't have to be this way right
like wherever your model is published
you can go and get it from there
but this is how i'm going to do it here
to demonstrate so this this model has a
predict
endpoint it's got a metrics endpoints
that are the testing metrics that we
expect to see
so i'm going to copy this url here and
then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to set up a post
call and i am going to um send as the
body
i'm gonna it's this crash this crash
data is what i'm gonna send
but i need to make it to
json oh you know what i don't think i've
loaded these yet
there we go okay so to jason and i'm
gonna do i'm gonna send it crash
i'm not gonna send the injuries though
and then uh so that would give me the
result and then i want
i want the uh
the text as utf
8 and that will be json at that point
so i'm going to do from json so these
are predictions
like so
like that so let's run this so this
these now
are predictions so it's sending for all
of those those new
crashes that i have that i want to use
for monitoring
it's sending them to the model getting
predictions for them
and then handling you know all of the
output here and getting back so what we
have at the
end there let me do it like this
is a vector like this so it's a vector
and these are probabilities
of having injuries we have our new crash
data
we have our model and then let's put it
together
and find our metrics so we take
that crash data and let's bind
on let's call it predict
underscore pred injuries so that's
so we just bind that on together so now
we have a column
of predicted probabilities let's make
a um let's
make a column of hard class
um prob uh hard
class predictions so if this
thing i just made
is greater than point five
let's call it injuries and
if it's not let's call it none so this
now matches
these so i'm making a hard class
prediction i think i need to say if
anything is a character
i need to change it to a factor right
there we go okay so because the
function that i'm about to use needs
factors
and that those functions are from the
yardstick package
so the yardstick package is from tidy
models
and you can use it with um
with models that have been trained with
tidy models or you can use it with
you know any other kinds of models and
get out these nice
results actually before i started
working for our studio
or using tidy models at all i used yards
yardstick was actually the first part of
this
whole ecosystem that i used at all
because it is so nice
and so we can do metrics and
the way we do it is we say the true
value
is in injuries and then we can say
um predicted and prepared injuries
so that it's the hard class and then the
class probabilities like this
and it gives us accuracy roc
and you look at this you're like is this
bad is this worse than what we
expect based on how the things did it
testing
this is what we want to know we probably
want to do a little bit more
because this is for that whole two weeks
and we probably
want to add a little bit more in here
and say
mutate uh so we've got a what's it
called
crash date crash date so we want to do a
little bit of some rounding here
actually let's do floor date say as
date crash date
and then we're going to say unit equals
week so now we're
rounding by the week that we have and
then we're just going to group by that
crash date
like this so now we have it for these
we've got three beginnings of weeks in
this data set
so we have these different values um
here
so these are the metrics
by week like this that we have
and if we are starting out our model
metrics we let's say we just
we just trained our model and we are
starting out
we would probably take this let's say we
trained our model on
you know march 20th we would start this
and we would
it would be time for us to start keeping
track of this and i think the
a great way to do this is the pins
package
i'm using the development version of
pins as of you know this recording it
will go to cran
soon but if you see me use you know some
of the
functions and things they might look a
little different than what's on cran
right now
but those functions will go there soon
and so what we want to do
is i actually have some
stored metrics in a pin right now
and so i'm going to show you how to get
them and then how to rewrite to them
but if you were starting from scratch
you would just start by writing without
reading first
the way that this works is let's say i
have to register a board
somewhere to store things so in pins
you can have a board on azure you can
have a board
on gosh there's so many there's on you
know google cloud storage
on github on kaggle
there's all these different kind of
boards that you can have i'm going to
show how to use a board on rstudio
connect
so my server is
the same thing as where my
where my model is deployed here
and then i need my key this is
and it is stored in my
in my dot our environ
file so i'm getting it out of there with
this here
that's a it's a pretty nice place to
store things
so i think if i type out board here
it'll be like
it's a pin board on our studio connect
and here are all the things that are
stored there like from my co-workers our
studio all these things
and i have something stored there too
if i do pin read
uh it's called uh it's it's can i spell
my own name
i don't know julia.silly and it's called
traffic
crash metrics and so if i read that and
i can say let's call it
old metrics like this
so i'm reading the old metrics
here so i've actually been monitoring
this model for a while now
but so i've been like monitoring
monitoring monitoring
and so now what i can do is i can
combine
the old metrics with the new metrics
and then write it back so i think the
way to do this
old metrics so i'm going to do like a
filter
that the this crash date
isn't in it
like that and then just bind them
together so this is the
this is kind of a nice way to do it so
that you don't
um you don't end up overwriting things
and all that kind of thing
um okay so if i do this there we go so i
have taken my
old metrics i have added on anything
that i have that's new
yeah so i can maybe i should arrange it
so it's the same
metric crash date like that there we go
and so i can write this back so we have
our old metrics my new
and the metrics by week and let's call
that new metrics
like this and then i can take my board
and i can write to it my new metrics
so i have to say where do i want to
write it to so i want to write it
to that same pin
like that and so it's writing back up
so what a pin gets you is a is
versioned ways to write things back and
forth which i think
is um really super duper nice
because you can always go back you can
also pin and version
models themselves it's really useful for
model
monitoring okay so look at that chunk
it's enormous so much is going on in it
um but this is like we have our new data
we have our model
we have our metrics and so now let's
just make a few visualizations
so i think for um the storyboard
i'm just going to put like different a
few things here so let's for example say
model metrics here and then we'll put
this we'll say
like new metrics
because that was all of it and let's say
what do we have
the new metrics
new metrics there was a bunch there were
several different kinds of metrics in
there so let's just
let's just do two and filter metric in
accuracy roc
auc and we can make a
um
say do a crash date estimate
like this and then we can put a um
geome line like so
and we'll say aes color equals metric
like that and i think that will need a
facet
wrap by metric
let's say free y
and and i think this will look better if
it's like they're on top of each other
like this
i think that looks pretty good so we'll
do something like this and then oh
yeah so i'm going to use plotly to do
these so let's do
let's save this as p and then let's do
gigi plotly
p like this so we'll need to we'll need
to also load
library plotly
like so let's see what that looks like
right
whoops no it's of source that's so silly
it's called plotly
right which i put there which is right
okay
okay all right
and i think we can do if i do it like
this
if i save it here as an
object and then i do hide
legend p yeah let's do that
nice okay so that's pretty good right
like this is our metric i can spend more
time and make this
you know nicer x equals a null
i mean i can definitely keep going and
like make this nicer in so many
different ways but this is pretty good
so model metrics i can go on i can you
know
i'm just gonna say like i could do um
i could make a map i could make a
table there are so many different things
i could do
and then i can if when i hit knit let's
see if this works
it's going to go through now and it's
going to do all the stuff in the setup
chunk which remember
get calls two different apis computes
all the metrics does all this kind of
stuff
and then it should pop out a dashboard
here for me
so so let's talk about what you might do
with this dashboard
so let's look at this here okay so what
might you do with this dashboard so this
dashboard does not use shiny
and we can you know put more narrative
in this place and you know maybe we put
our other
things that we would have here so the
dashboard like this
what i would do with it is i would
publish it somewhere where i could
update it once a week in this case right
and and then um you know be able to look
at it
whenever i wanted to i have this
published in the example that we can
show you
on rstudio connect which of course has
this great feature of where i can
schedule it to run on our studio connect
once a week send me a nice email
saying that it succeeded and send me a
plot and all this kind of thing
but if you publish your our markdown
documents in a different way you can
pursue that in whatever way is
appropriate to your own data
infrastructure
what i want you to take as a takeaway
here is that
model monitoring requires you to think
about what are the pieces
that are required that are important to
you your model your data
and then there are components of the our
ecosystem today
that lets you move forward with the kind
of model monitoring that you need to do